Hello Freak bitches to play devil's advocate or the,
you know,
the argument against it.
Like what about things like,
you know,
the serious situation,
I believe it was Chevrolet had um,
some ignition issues that they knew about where cars were cutting out and it
caused a bunch of deaths and a lot of people were aware of this issue,
but they knew that a recall would be incredibly expensive and they drag their
heels and they didn't do anything about it for a long time and now it's just a
fucking complete disaster and they're getting sued like crazy.
I got,
what about that kind of situation?
Like it's kind of important to have wars.
I mean,
obviously the balance,
it's like,
do you have an army?
Yes.
Do you invade Canada?
No.
Do you have police?
Yes.
Do they shoot every person darker than them walking down the sidewalk?
No.
Do you have lawyers?
Yes.
Do you have shitloads of lawyers that are suing everyone?
All the time?
No.
Like,
so there's,
you know the balance.
There's reasons to sue.
Yeah.
You,
you know the Ford Pinto,
I had two of my best friends died about three miles from here in a pinto station
wagon that was in an accident and burst into flames.
Yeah.
Does the classic story that we had all heard.
You actually knew people like
Robert [inaudible] from way back,
fuck going to Csun,
God damn car carpooling together.
Crazy like 18 just rear ended,
two cars banged up next to him,
like couldn't get out.
Whole car just went up.
Fuck.
Yup.
It's crazy.
Right?
He always wonder like what,
what would have those guys gone on to,
what could they have done?
And it's also weird that even though they died when they were 18 they're still
always my age,
whatever age I am,
which is a weird thing.
It,
it was in and it's one of those,
in that case there needed to be lawyers and Ford knew about it.
And for dot,
you know,
let Robert and Lenny died.
It'll be cheaper than recalling,
you know,
2.7 million units or whatever,
whatever it was.
And outfitting them.
I think just whack.
We'd,
there's Mexican dirt weed to Shitty weed.
Thai stick.
Yeah,
but it's all weed.
But he gave me some,
and I play golf with my grandma,
my aunt the next day and apply whole five.
I was like just coming down.
I realized when we were hitting the guard and she's a conservative person,
her husband is like a lawyer and like it's conservative so that it's like once I
realized I was high,
it was like keep your mouth shut dude.
But if you get that wave right,
like the other night Aubrey and I were playing pool and um,
I don't really play that much anymore,
man.
I don't get a chance.
I don't play in tournaments anymore.
I don't get a chance to play too many.
Like sometimes dom Arrera nine we'll get together or Greg Fitzsimmons place
pretty good.
We'll get together.
You played pretty good and we'll get together and knocks the balls around.
But I'm not like playing like real players.
I can tournaments or anything anymore.
And so I think,
but every now and then like you get high and you remember what to do.
You remember how to do it?
The other day I got into,
I got zone for like five,
six shots in a row.
I started like,
I started running out like this table I should getting out over and over and
over again and the way that I really shouldn't be able to do because I'm really
not practicing that much,
but I just got into the zone.
It was very temporary.
I couldn't hold it,
but I knew it was all the weed.
I knew it.
I know like I know how to play pool a little bit,
but I'm in this crazy sensitive zone.
Why know how to control that ball better?
It's two ways it can hit you by two on basketball and sometimes in basketball
it's like someone will throw you a pass and Walton the area go,
okay,
what am I options here?
When the ball gets to me,
I got him cutting.
I could pass the him,
I could shoot,
I could pass it back and it's like,
all right,
I'm ready.
I think I'm right and then the ball comes to you.
Other Times that ball just hits you in the face.
I was like,
why are you playing high?
It's so true.
Where cats,
our pets,
he's,
you stop smelling cats' litter boxes.
I just put down my cat that I talked about last time I was on the show and for
my first time in 17 years,
I get to have a house that has no litter box and I don't even know what that's
like.
You're lazy too.
I don't think you can
do it every day.
Oh yeah.
It's like,
oh,
once a week.
Just throw it new litter box.
Oh my God.
See that's the problem.
You have to do that every day.
Otherwise you're breathing shit.
Did you hire a maid penalty fumes?
I,
I've had a maid right now.
I don't have a man.
You've got to get a maid watching one of those top was made so they have one
that you did that.
I tried that.
I told you that you did try that?
Yeah.
How'd it go?
It's not good.
It's really bad.
It was like a older woman and his,
her daughter I think.
And you can't choose who you get to.
Not Topless.
Why?
I don't know.
There's like a few different companies,
but when I did,
I just,
there's a van parked down my street so I just called it and I can just gawking
guy like you rub maps,
massage pose,
right.
Why wouldn't you at least do a fine Yelp review?
It said 99 bucks.
I wasn't really thinking into it and like I didn't think like,
oh wait,
I have to watch them clean because I made it and I'm like one of the guys that
hides cause I'm so ashamed.
But then like you just kind of stand there in the kitchen going up.
If she's topless,
this is stupid.
What am I doing this?
She really cleaning or do a bad job.
No,
they're,
they're just doing,
they're just regular mates that are getting an extra 20 bucks to take their top
off I think because these are,
these are people that are like,
they seem like they were related and it seemed like just normal mate.
It was very,
very uncomfortable.
I kind of like it.
I felt very bad
because it was like sad.
This was an older woman,
like how old?
50 and maybe hit her daughter.
That's was maybe,
are you sure with your daughter?
It seemed like a mom and daughter.
It was really fucked up.
That's tough.
Well,
you know,
you gotta think if you know someone that's really fucked up and they have a kid,
that kid's going to grow up with a fucked up parent.
Like if someone's like really crazy or you know,
if someone is a top was made for living and they don't think there's anything
wrong with it and then you know,
your daughter hits 18 she's like,
mom,
I want to join.
The top was made business.
You're like,
hey,
it's good enough for me.
Why isn't it good enough for you?
Yeah,
the mom was a little,
oh true.
Very true.
Then mine was a little overweight,
but she had humongous Mexican tits and when she took her bra off,
it had the most horrific stretch marks from our broad digging into her
rotations.
It was,
it looked like talk to her like when she took her tits out.
No,
I just sat there and they both just put it in a bucket.
Like they just put their clothes.
They didn't,
we didn't list it like they didn't talk or anything.
They didn't say like,
hello.
They said hello when we came in,
but they were like,
not any English or like,
I just like the kitchen living room.
I hadn't cleaned the kitchen living room in the bathroom.
I namely let them go and you should have said huge Mexican tits or something
like that.
They speak uncomfortable.
They speak English,
right?
Uh,
barely.
They like,
I remembered that they asked where the vacuum cleaner wasn't.
It was very like,
oh that's cool.
Have you looked under your huge Mexican?
I would always wonder like,
what does that life like?
I would have to ask them questions.
I would give them extra money just to be able to ask questions.
I'll say,
I'll pay you for a whole extra hour if you sit down for another five minutes.
Just let me,
how was the,
how was the daughter attractive?
The daughter wasn't bad,
but it she was a little chubby or also like they were both a little chubby but
the mom's boobs were weird cause they had,
she had the huge like hanging ones and she was cleaning the kitchen and I just,
I would like just kind of walk in and just be like,
oh this is going on in here.
And it hurt just dirty boobs.
Like touching the oven.
Oh,
while she's cleaning it.
You have made it sound very sad.
There's nothing,
it was horrible.
I do not recommend it.
I just would want to talk to them and find out what that's like.
Like the guys like try to attack you.
Like that seems like a dangerous kid.
I hope that's why they do it though because there's so,
they weren't very appealing and it was sad that I think it was like a onetime
thing.
I would rather pay.
It was a one time for them.
I think once you get it,
you're not going to have them come back ever again.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's almost a joke.
Almost mean a one time thing for you.
Yeah,
I want to talk to them for that.
Would you?
I would rather do for 20 extra bucks,
get regular made,
but I could be bottomless and they would not like get mad at me.
Like I would just sit in there with normal mates and just have no pants on.
That'd be better.
Right.
I think that's illegal unless you make it.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
The agreement is,
I don't have to have where parents,
well,
I'm sure someone can do that,
Brian.
Sure.
That's a great,
well,
you have to want to have your pants off with them too,
so they'd have to be like these somewhat attractive.
Right.
You're allowed to stroke and just follow them around,
but they can't call it.
That's rude
in a way,
in your little narrow hallway and accidentally come on them.
I don't know.
Like clean it up in this city.
You could definitely work.
Workout your fantasy.
Yeah.
That's a minor request.
You could work out some pretty crazy shit in this town.
Yeah.